il faut d'abord comment ça va depuis 5
ans on a fêté
de la mort ton papa est un peu plus d'un
an comment ça va en vrai ça va parce que
je vais relativiser on arrive bien se
sortir on soutient beaucoup avec ma
maman mon frère mon frère ma sœur la
famille on est très soudé donc ça aide
beaucoup
vous êtes soudé tous ensemble
après c'est vrai que se dire que ça fait
déjà un an c'est hyper bizarre parce
qu'en fait on se rend compte qu'en un an
j'ai pas fait grand chose de plus
qu'avant et que la vie elle a fini enfin
juste elle a continué comme si de rien
n'était il y a un truc qui était très
mignon je suis allé dans un club de
vacances où vous alliez souvent et vous
veniez d'y aller avec ton père on m'a
dit ils viennent de partir et quelques
temps après ton papa est parti j'ai eu
le sentiment en tout cas que lui il est
pensé plus que vous et qui voulait il
voulait vous offrir les dernières
vacances tous ensemble en famille est-ce
que c'est un truc comme ça je pense que
au jamais savait parce qu'il y avait pas
mal de petits trucs qui déconnaient au
niveau de sa santé donc je pense qu'il
le savait après il faisait toujours
comme si de rien n'était donc
les sentiments et la peur c'est pas du
tout là et du coup ça m'a donné question
là-dessus quand il est parti
Isabelle l'a dit il est arrivé à
l'hôpital pour autre chose donc on sait
pas du tout qui partirait il vous en
avez parlé avant tu le savais ça a été
un choc total nous on est allé à
l'hôpital parce qu'il a fait plusieurs
AVC donc nous on était ma mère elle est
énormément à l'hôpital tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours moi
j'allais au max parce que j'avais mes
études mon frère pareil donc en soi on
pouvait s'y préparer mais à moitié parce
qu'on peut jamais vraiment se préparer
mais
voilà quand tu vois la violence des
réseaux sociaux j'ai lu des choses comme
vraiment je le dis parce que j'ai
connaissais Twitter encore si c'était
moi
quand je vois des gens qui disent par
exemple tetrich bien fait pour ta gueule
ça tombe sur toi aussi d'abord j'ai lu
ces choses-là d'abord moi je l'ai jamais
pour de la vérité pardon mais j'ai très
peu les réseaux parce que ça me fait du
mal moi j'ai des U ta mère doit se
retrouver sur tourner dans sa tombe
quand elle te voit sale PDG tout ça
malgré tout ça fait mal quand tu es
débile on est copines de ça quand tu
quand tu lis ces choses là tu tu peux te
protéger de tout ça pendant un an tu te
fais c'est il y a une part de nous on se
dit que les commentaires c'est que des
commentaires et que c'est des gens
frustrés et une autre partie de nous on
se dit mais en fait les gens le pensent
vraiment en fait et c'est ça qui est
assez compliqué après on va ça fait mal
quand tu le lis quand même ça fait mal
mais je suis pas la seule qui est
touchée par le harcèlement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la lutte contre le cyber
harcèlement elle est pas que pour moi
elle est pour tous les jeunes et même
encore plus jeune que moi qui sont
harcelés on va rappeler que je suis
harcèlement est facile de choix c'est
trois ans jusqu'à trois ans de prison
45000 euros d'amende donc on peut pas
critiquer les gens comme ça sans
penser à la personnalité d'ailleurs moi
j'avais fait un pardon après
rassurez-vous avec toi tu euh j'avais
fait un sujet sur ton frère Tom
en amour et ça maman un sujet qui était
passé sur sur TF1 très bien je suis
d'ailleurs si vous le revoir et elle
vivait dans une maison on va pas dire où
près de Versailles tout ça vous avez
déménagé depuis c'est c'est comment
c'est un nouvel endroit du coup ça a
aidé de déménager vous êtes tous
ensemble juste à vous trois mon frère
habite à Lille moi j'ai un minable pour
ses études il est à Lille moi j'ai
emménagé à Paris genre ta mère est seule
ouais bah il y a ça ma meilleure amie à
Muriel mais on habite seul en fait c'est
une demi maison avec Muriel en haut et
comment tu la sent ta maman du coup
Nathalie tu vas l'avoir le weekend
même souvent en semaine vu que mon stage
il est pas trop loin je fais des
allers-retours et je vais la voir donc
ça va j'ai encore deux trois petit
vous êtes une famille vous avez toujours
un peu tout dit atelier d'expliquer la
maladie Jean-Pierre j'ai jamais
rencontré de mes vies sauf deux fois ici
et je te promets j'ai compris pourquoi
il avait cette carrière ça s'appelle la
générosité je pensais qu'elle est pue
pendant les 7 minutes il me parler même
pas il s'est tourné et pour 7 minutes il
va parler de moi des machins pourquoi le
Père Noël me parle tu vois ce que je
veux dire j'ai compris journal la
simplicité de ce monsieur et sa
gentillesse mais ma question c'était
quand par hasard tu vois
ta maman fait un an de sa mort avec un
gâteau une bougie vous soufflez tous
ensemble
est-ce que tu peux comprendre que il y a
des gens qui puissent se dire c'est un
peu impudique faites sans ne montrez pas
tout je peux comprendre qu'il y a des
personnes qui
absolument c'est ça chacun fait son day
à sa manière je peux comprendre qu'il y
a des personnes qui ne feraient pas
pareil que nous c'est normal le chacun
sa manière de voir les choses après on
sait qu'on perd était très proche des
Français donc il y a énormément de gens
que ça fait pas que ça fait plaisir
qu'on parle de mon papa et que
par exemple à Amiens il y a l'office du
tourisme d'Amiens qui s'est renommé
office du tourisme Jean-Pierre Pernaut
moi je l'ai vécu et sur le réseau il y a
plein de gens qui étaient contents
au final on parle toujours de quoi tu
veux faire parce que parce que il y en a
assez peu mobile il y en a une il ne
veut pas qu'on parle d'elle mais de ses
médecins l'autre automobile et toi j'ai
appris que tu voulais être chroniqueuse
et tu vas être que tu vas être connu tu
vas célèbre non alors je veux pas être
célèbre pour être célèbre juste cette
chaîne pour véhiculer les bons messages
parce que je pense que à la télé je vous
adore tous ici nous offens contre vous
vraiment c'est juste qu'il y a très
rarement des jeunes de 20 ans donc
peut-être que j'ai pas les connaissances
requises peut-être que j'ai pas la
maturité
par exemple sur les réseaux sociaux où
vous êtes très sûrement sans vouloir
vous vexer encore une fois moins calé
que moi et du coup c'est vrai qu'il y a
vraiment
clac clac elle y va 36 15 du là ça roule
en fait si j'ai envie de faire de la
télé c'est pour véhiculer les bons
messages que les personnes de mon âge ne
font pas forcément comme je disais
pas de modèle à faire TPMP
bonjour sur le sur le harcèlement parce
que j'ai vu que tu avais posté avant de
venir sur Tik Tok un petit message une
petite vidéo tu dis que
99,9% des messages qui te font du mal
mais que tu arrives à tenir uniquement
pour les 0,0 1% donc vu que tu as un
million et demi sur Tik Tok 200000 sur
Instagram le quotidien doit être mais
pourquoi tu parles comme ça j'abuse un
petit peu quand j'ai 99,9 c'est vraiment
bien renseigné
comment je tiens parce que je me dis que
je vais pas me gâcher la vie pour des
gens qui n'en valent pas la peine
mais ça me touche quand même quand j'ai
fait l'interview Jordan Deluxe j'ai eu
des tonnes et des tonnes et des tonnes
de messages négatifs mais je pleurais et
tout j'ai supprimé Jordan de supprimer